please welcome the gold medal award
winning film egg maker in the
alternative category Veritate you tie
Sri hello whoo yeah I always want to do
that oh I'm so true you know this is the
first time for for me because I used to
be a graphic designer so to be in this
honored award and it is so unbelievable
so so I would like to thank academy and
Oscar and that give me the opportunity
to be here today also I would like to
thank my DP to no shimmer production
manager Tom Tita wanchai Wong composer
plum my advisor Marie hi Catherine
Milwaukee and an ostrich epic at the new
school all my cast day from this I'll
friend you know that they contribute a
lot of good feed for me you know they
have a dog to to bring a dog and pass
instead doing school for design which
you know they gave me such a good
opportunity to to do some crazy stuff
and you know it's not very very easy to
get this idea across when you try to
explain to people and you think there
might be some purple stuff but all right
you know it turned out to be nice and
that's it that's it I'm thank you
everybody to come out today
you